la Unión Europea ha seguido con osuma
atención las complicadas últimas horas
que ha vivido Perú desde la comisión
europea ha habido un claro rechazo
cualquier atentado al Estado de derecho
y a la Constitución peruana un portavoz
de esta institución Europea de hecho ha
valorado aún así que la situación se
esté encausando por la vía pacífica
democrática y según el marco
constitucional peruano pero también ha
pedido a todos los actores políticos que
actúen según la legalidad de las últimas
horas también se emitió un comunicado
por parte de todos los países de la
Unión Europea en que aseguran que apoyan
toda solución política y democrática y
pacífica adoptada por las instituciones
peruanas aún así pide diálogo para
asegurar la estabilidad de todo el país